chris brown congratulates ex-girlfriend
rihanna following the birth of her and
asap rocky's baby boy it's a long nine
to ten months girl you know you you have
to enjoy it the rapper shares his well
wishes on social media soon after the
happy news became public while it
doesn't name rihanna outright the
message says congratulations alongside
emojis for a pregnant woman prayer hands
and a red heart brown and rihanna's
relationship history is a tumultuous one
the two began dating in 2007 and the
relationship ended in 2009 with brown's
domestic violence toward rihanna coming
to light that same year on the night of
the grammy awards brown attacked rihanna
following an argument he later turned
himself in and was charged with felony
assault the two reportedly rekindled
their romance from 2012 to 2013.
you've grown up since since then what
have you learned since then what about
that situation speaking with e.t in 2014
brown said he's forgiven himself you
know you learn from your mistakes also
that you know you're right from wrong
everybody knows right from wrong so
in that situation you just have to be
you have to forgive yourself one you
know you can't beat yourself up over the
years because just eat away at you and
you'll just be stuck in the past you
know and but for me i just learned most
of all just to be more of a humble
individual and more of a
conscious person
he later got candid about the 2009
incident in his documentary chris brown
welcome to my life but then i really hit
him like i got with the closed fist like
i punched him you know and it uh busted
her lip
and when i saw it i was in shock i was
like
why the hell i hit her i loved her you
know i i wanted to protect her because i
did too much stuff to her
like i did what i did so it was wrong
that's not me bro that's not that's not
me like
i just i hate it to this day you know
what i'm saying that's gonna haunt me
forever but back to rihanna and asap
following several music collabs over the
years the two began dating in 2020. in
january rihanna announced she was
pregnant with the couple's first child
and it is learning new details about the
parents a source tells et quote they are
over the moon she has been looking
forward to motherhood for a long time
this little boy is going to have the
best baby fashion i'm honestly truly
blessed bro as for asap another source
tells e.t before rihanna gave birth asap
was super involved and was asking his
friends for parenting advice quote he
wants to be the best dad possible and
continue to take care of rihanna they
are such a down-to-earth couple have
similar styles and couldn't be more in
love and happy about this next chapter
[Music]